ah you smell APRA's that's the smell
some fresh [ __ ] rail bridges alright I
know how to build a bridge thank you
very much
this'll do the trick
what okay this is genius maybe not that
genius and you call yourself a tractor
I mean bus can they do it yes they help
him help help a brother out
that's it you got it okay if this
doesn't work I am my mind is blown damn
it
yes yes it working the plan is working
I study civil engineering this is my
forte this is what I don't this is my
laughs all right here we go
well god damn it of it oh they're going
of course
there's spider trucks why did no one
tell me there were spider trucks this
completely have makes this has to change
the aerodynamic design of dammit all
right this has to work right
or not okay if this doesn't work I will
cry a baby this is the best damn cry a
baby yes dammit keep fighting
he's got it he's got it he's got it he's
got it what what wait wait it's working
nah this is a bridge [ __ ]
now we're talking costly effective
bridge all right yes yeah this has to be
the best bridge of all time oh my god
share it on Facebook how how is that
possible
where do you go what is happening here
ah yeah such a nice little bridge people
and people not appreciate bridges
anymore like I don't understand why
people can't just be [ __ ] thankful
for the bridges of the world you don't
know a good bridge when you see one you
better hold it
you better [ __ ] hold it damn it yet
again y'all get it slots forever new I
got an achievement alright I'll take it
sorry again no one likes you anyway yes
this will work flawlessly come on baby
don't keep going keep going keep going
keep going keep going
hurry hurry damn it yes yes best bridge
ever Oh chair that [ __ ] on Facebook
[ __ ] Stace you call that a bridge it's
the most depressing bridge ever seen in
my life if this bridge doesn't work I
quit life okay you don't know if you
don't try damn it damn it keep going
keep going keep going you can do it you
can do it
juergen is dead but you can do it Martin
Martin Martin you you're not a submarine
damn it we needed to deliver those
chicken nuggets it's gonna break damn it
it's gonna break go fast go fast [ __ ]
where's your sonic spirit how where's
your [ __ ] sonic spirit all right
this doesn't work I'm gonna cry a real
tears look at this [ __ ] look at it oh oh
no no no my perfect man
No ah bah it was going so well
don't you dare break on me oh god it
doesn't look good all they're so red oh
we did ha ha woo share on Facebook
oh god my friends are gonna be so
jealous yes yes this works [ __ ]
go go go go go yes well sorry sorry
Martin one had to be sacrificed you can
be a mountain now your dream is true
come on [ __ ] keep fighting you piece
of [ __ ] oh oh that is the best preach a
machinima laughs thank you
yeah that was amazing Shepard all my
non-existing friends on Facebook I mean
who wouldn't want to go on a bridge like
this if you wanted to die at least now
this is the greatest [ __ ] bridge ever
known to mankind I can't afford anything
else damn it but this will be the
greatest [ __ ] break [ __ ]
here we go come on maybe
damnit I don't think I thought this one
through go go go
you can do it trucks yes come on come on
Ash
instead of a [ __ ] she left your friend
nailed it
come on keep going come on keep going
down yes beautiful
ha ha ha ha that's a good one
oh-oh-oh-oh go faster damn it
faster damn it [ __ ] yes this will work
damn it
go truck go come on you piece of [ __ ]
go faster that's right you can do it I
have full faith in you truck
see you later truck go truck go go truck
go go truck go truck go truck go damn it
[ __ ] come on
yes yes ha ha ha ha that's my lady's
Imbros how you finish a damn bridge hits
the sky recover today and I will see you
Bros in the next one stay awesome Road